As you might have intuited
from the exercise,
some more cleverness will be needed
to make this process efficient.
Even the evaluation of polynomials
at arbitrary points will
take quadratic time.
For each point, we need to do
a number of multiplications and
additions that is proportional
to the number of coefficients.
The most efficient way to do
this is via Horner's rule.
You can find the link in
the instructor's notes.
You can also think about filling
out the Vandermonde matrix and
then doing the matrix multiplication.
Regardless, for arbitrary points, we
end up with the quadratic running time.
Multiplying in the value
domain takes order (n+m) time.
Since we just multiply the values for
the corresponding inputs,
xj, this part is fine.
Interpolation involves solving
a system of equations with
n + m equations and n + m unknowns.
By Gaussian elimination,
this would take order (n + m)
cubed time in the worst case.
For Vandermonde matrices, however,
there's also a method called Lagrange
interpolation that allows us to do
this in time that's just quadratic.
Note, however,
that this still isn't good enough.
In fact, we're at essentially the same
running time as we have for convolution.
Is there any hope?
Well, yes there is.
All of these running times pertain to
an arbitrary set of values for X here.
But since we're only interested in
the coefficients of the product,
polynomial C,
we get to choose all these X.
And as it turns out,
this freedom is very, very powerful.